David Biello: So tell me about ReNew2030.
Rebecca Colyer: David, ReNew2030
is a coalition of regional climate
foundations, think tanks and NGOs
working around the world
to scale wind and solar.
Why is this so important
in the fight to protect our climate?
Well, because the power sector
is responsible for 50 percent
of all the emissions
we need to reduce before 2030.
It needs to go first
because we need it
to electrify other sectors.
We also need to make sure
that the transition is fast.
As well as first,
it needs to go fast.
We've got a window of just seven years.
Seven years to see those exponential
curves hit the roof.
And it also needs to be fair.
We need to make sure
that the communities involved
are consulted deeply on the siting
of those renewable energy installations.
We need to make sure
that the supply chains
and the transition minerals
are equitably sourced.
And we also need to make sure
that precious finance flows
to where it's needed most.
So this is what ReNew2030 does.
Powered by philanthropy,
it takes the funds to the groups
that need it most
in the geographies
where the transition needs the most
in order to impact the power sector.
DB: So what are the obstacles then?
RC: You'd think, with the phenomenal cost
reductions we've seen in renewable energy,
that this would just be
a runaway success story.
But that's not the case.
There are all sorts of non-cost barriers
that communities and societies
need to work on.
Barriers such as lack of ambition,
policy barriers,
such as lack of investment,
barriers such as slow
permitting and planning,
not just for wind and solar themselves,
but also for the grids that we need
to balance them reliably and securely.
Barriers like misinformation.
In the information wars
we’ve been talking about,
there are really serious problems
about misinformation.
And of course, skills for workers
and a just transition.
So, David, ReNew2030,
what it does is it supports groups
and it does so with a set of levers.
Levers that are tried and tested
to help us work on the transition,
policy and advocacy, to name just a few.
Narrative building and storytelling.
And we do that across the globe,
in the geographies that have
the highest emissions,
and we support groups
working on those barriers.
I want to tell you a little bit more
about some of those groups.
Sérgio Xavier works
in the northeast of Brazil.
And they're working to advocate
for sustainable energy products.
Abdou Ndour, he works in Senegal helping
agricultural workers to access energy.
Joojin Kim, he works in South Korea
and he works on policy and finance.
And one of my personal favorite partners
that we support is Jeanette Gitobu.
She helps female leaders and engineers
to enter careers
in the global wind industry.
So that’s what ReNew2030 does.
It helps bring the power of philanthropy
to the groups that matter the most.
DB: That's amazing.
But that also makes it sound
like communities are maybe as important
as national governments in this?
RC: That's right, David.
I mean, for many years we've focused
on national governments
and they are critical, don't get me wrong,
they're really, really important.
But communities have incredible power
to shape the power system of the future
that we want to see.
They can engage in community-owned energy,
they can engage in local policy.
They can engage in the workforce
as part of a just transition.
So communities are central
to the thesis of ReNew2030.
DB: OK, so, sounds great,
but what makes you think
that this collaborative
approach will work?
I mean, you've got lots of progress,
but we need exponential change,
as you said.
RC: We do need exponential change, David.
This is what worries me.
So we have to collaborate
between businesses,
governments and civil society.
And we've seen in countries like Uruguay,
Denmark, Kenya, many others,
that exponential growth is possible.
So what ReNew2030 does
is it works with a group of regional
climate foundation leaders
to bring the funding
to the groups on the ground
with the data they need,
the tool kit of strategies
and also the ability to convene
together and talk and listen.
And ReNew2030 is therefore the thing
that gives me great hope
that we can see exponential growth
in the places that we need.
DB: I love the sound of that.
So when you succeed,
what does the world of 2030 look like?
RC: We actually need these groups
to create disruptive change.
Times five
the installation of wind and solar
that we have now by 2030,
done in a just and equitable way.
So my hope is that by 2030,
the work that we do
will have helped put us on a footing
for a climate secure, safe future.
It's 50 percent of all emissions
we need to get at, remember.
So this is very serious.
And my hope is that at the same time,
we will actually have created
local jobs and clean air.
And most importantly for me personally,
is that we will have helped
to give communities
the opportunity to shape affordable,
clean electricity for their homes
and their schools and their businesses.
Thank you.
DB: Thank you.
(Applause)